- Une communauté une fois
de plus éplorée.
Sur les 13 victimes,
11 étaient afro-américaines,
10 sont mortes.
Une fusillade diffusée en direct
sur les réseaux sociaux par
ce tireur de 18 ans, qui aurait
hurlé des injures racistes
en tirant sur les gens.
"Ce crime, dit-elle, a été
commis par un individu malade
et dément, nourri par la haine."
Une haine publiée dans
un document de 180 pages mis
en ligne par le suspect.
Il se qualifierait
de suprémaciste blanc
et d'antisémite. Les enquêteurs
analysent le manifeste,
où il expliquerait en détail
son plan pour cibler
des quartiers noirs.
"C'est le mal absolu, dit-il,
motivé par la haine raciale...
Venant d'une personne qui n'est
même pas de notre communauté."
L'enquête judiciaire porte
sur le crime haineux, motivé
par des groupes de suprématie
blanche et d'extrémisme violent.
"Il faut qu'on travaille
ensemble pour combattre
cette haine, dit le président,
qui demeure une tache
sur l'âme de l'Amérique."
Une haine répandue
sur les réseaux sociaux,
mais aussi diffusés
sur les grands réseaux
de télévision, comme la chaine
Fox News, dit cet analyste.
"Les Américains blancs se font
dire quotidiennement qu'il faut
qu'ils résistent à la crise
démographique, dit-il,
sinon c'est la théorie
du grand remplacement."
Selon le maire, il faut
condamner les personnalités
médiatiques et les politiciens
qui diffusent cette haine.
Avec cette tuerie,
la question du contrôle
des armes aux États-Unis
refait surface, ainsi
que l'accès aux chargeurs
de grande capacité.
(chant)
En attendant, la communauté
de Buffalo se relève
de cette fusillade insensée,
qui rappelle celle
de Charlestone, en Caroline
du Sud en 2015, où neuf
personnes afro-américaines
avaient été tuées dans
leur église, par un jeune
extremiste blanc.
La vice-présidente, Kamala
Harris, a affirmé qu'une attaque
sur une communauté était
une attaque sur toute la nation.
Et le FBI a de nouveaux indiqué
que le terrorisme intérieur
était la principale menace
aux États-Unis.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis.
Radio-Canada, Washingto